merci d'être venu aussi nombreux à cette
réunion parents professeur
sincèrement je suis surprise j'ai pas
l'habitude
vous demandez pourquoi
parce qu'en tant professeur d'art
plastique les parents ne viennent pas
toujours me voir pour parler d'art ou de
la scolarité de leurs enfants
c'est dommage bon ce soir parmi vous
peut-être que certains n'ont pas
d'enfant
s beaucoup moins de soucis
[Applaudissements]
je les adore vos enfants bon seulement
voilà l'école et l'éducation c'est un
sujet commun c'est un peu comme la météo
à tout le monde peut en parler tout le
monde a une idée sur la question et en
plus
on est tous passés par là
ainsi j'ai deux passions dans la vie la
pédagogie
elle a
savez-vous que les arts plastiques sont
la discipline la plus importante dans
toute la scolarité de vos enfants
je précise les arts en général sont la
matière la plus importante la plus
essentielle la plus existentielle
oui oui j'en vois bien qu'ils sont
encore un peu sceptique
[Musique]
c'est rien c'est probablement dû à
l'effet de surprise
rappelez-vous la petite enfance la
petite enfant c'est une époque où tout
est effectivement niveau sensitif etc
on apprend à marcher à faire plein de
choses et surtout
on adore ces salir et voilà
alors bien sûr vous demandez de aux
autres de s'occuper de ça donc soit à la
crèche soit au centre aéré parce que la
peinture c'est bien trop ça
et que la créativité sur les murs de la
chambre je m'en repein c'est aboli
pourquoi j'en connais qui ont fait
carrière comme ça moi pensez au street
art
alors voilà vous sentons sont capables
de merveilles mais vous ne les laissez
pas cesser et bien ce que vous vous ne
voyez pas moi je le vois en cours d'art
plastique
et je m'émerveille de leur don et de
leur talent
oui je vois bien ce qui se trame dans
vos petits esprits taquins ouais c'est
normal
stop
Abba les stéréotypes sur les professeurs
d'arts plastiques
on dit qu'on est toujours à l'ouest
même à l'ouest en dehors des sentiers
battus pour garder les pieds sur terre
on dit aussi qu'on est toujours perché
c'est plutôt une qualité c'est avoir de
la hauteur
on dit aussi qu'on aime beaucoup les
couleurs
je vois moi
on dit aussi que c'est le bazar dans
notre salle
et dans notre tête
pas du tout c'est la façon de ranger et
de hiérarchiser qui change
heureusement je suis pas toute seule
j'ai mes élèves et Zoé peut témoigner de
mon côté psychomania du rangement et du
classement
dans la salle d'art plastique on range
les pinceaux dans l'ordre croissant dans
la salle d'arts plastiques on trie les
papiers
on ne jette rien de ce qui est
normalement destiné aux recyclage au cas
où cela pourrait provoquer l'idée du
coup faut bien essayer de ranger un
petit peu donc dans la salle d'arts
plastiques orange on nettoie
on classe par rubrique par matière
chaque chose à sa place bon
pour autant je croise les parents de Zoé
en réunion parents professeur alors il
m'octroyait tout le mérite de son goût
pour les arts plastiques de son goût
pour la collection bon jusqu'ici tout va
bien
cela dit je me permets comme une petite
parenthèse moi toutes les heures en
cours d'art plastique je vois 30 ados
qui débarquent dans leur chambre donc
vous vous rendez bien compte que je suis
habité à ranger classé et qui chaque
chose à sa place
du coup je mets Zoé au défi et je lui
dis
range ta chambre en fonction des
critères de classement la salle d'art
plastique
je demandais une photo pour preuve
et bien sûr sa chambre était impeccable
tout le problème ne venait pas des arts
plastiques
on dit aussi que le talent du dessin
c'est inné on s'est dessiné on sait pas
dessiné du coup les parents pensent que
les enfants
s'amusent plus en art qui ne travaille
mais enfin on peut quand même travailler
on s'amusant et prendre plaisir à
travailler
ça c'est le principal
alors ce n'est pas le seul stéréotype
qu'on est pour autant à la maternelle
les arts sont rois on est bien d'accord
ça va développer la psychomotricité des
enfants
sa valeur permet de s'exercer au niveau
de la psychomotricie c'est fine ça va
aussi leur permettre de développer des
relationnel lorsqu'il y a des oeuvres
collectives donc les arts sont rois on
se rend compte qu'ils permettent de
faire grandir nos bambins et qu'en plus
c'est un levier pour une intégration
sociale heureuse excusez-moi du peu
bon alcool primaire les premières années
ça perturbe ça perdure pour les mêmes
raisons on sait que par les arts on va
développer les repères spatiaux
temporels on sait qu'on va développer la
relation à l'autre on sait qu'on va
développer lassurance d'accord et on va
aussi partager de l'émotion
souvenez-vous du magnifique cadeau que
vous avez tous les ans pour la Fête des
Mères La fête des pères
un magnifique collier de nouilles
un cache-pot ou un cendrier vous avez
jamais su mais bon comme vous êtes
non-fumeur vous optez pour le cache-pot
donc vous rendez bien compte qu'il
s'agit de partager de l'émotion de faire
un don d'amour en quelque sorte bien
d'accord mais les bienfaits de l'art ne
s'arrêtent pas là c'est à dire c'est
quand même un comble et c'est fou quelle
école on apprenne un savoir-faire un
savoir-être et un développement
personnel et tout ça grâce aux arts bien
sûr alors c'est un art qu'on apprend à
s'épanouir apprendre la parole devant
les autres
à communiquer à mettre des mots sur ses
émotions
et pourtant pourtant
alors que la mission de l'école est
d'apprendre à lire écrire compter
le pouvoir et la valeur des arts
semblent s'amener progressivement
on passe des rois
des arts loisirs
pourquoi
croyez-vous vraiment que d'apprendre à
communiquer les autres avec les autres
et avoir des repères
deviennent secondaires
non absolument pas
mais simplement comme c'est un petit peu
marginal dans la scolarité
parce que dans la scolarité qui est nul
complètement le plaisir
on n'est pas habitué à apprendre avec
plaisir et où on prend à la fois
l'individu dans son corps et dans son
esprit
mais bon
tout ça c'est bien abstrait sans la
présence de nos élèves
parce que finalement c'est les élèves
qui nous apprennent le plus alors
souvenir d'un cours de 6e
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
les planètes du système solaire donc
c'est en partenariat avec la science
physique nous avons donc réfléchi sur
tout ce qui était la question de la
matérialité la matérialité en arts
plastiques c'est à la fois le format et
la texture comment est-ce que c'est
fabriqué avec une dimension aussi
symbolique et nous travaillons donc sur
un focus que les élèves ont choisi
eux-mêmes donc sur Mars et Vénus donc
nous sommes en réalisation et à ce
moment là
j'adore les arts ça me bronzaine ça me
détend
c'est vrai que je me suis pas posé la
question de savoir qu'est-ce que vous
éprouviez lorsque vous viviez des arts
du coup je remédiatise un petit peu la
question parce que c'est pour des 6e ils
ont entre 9 et 10 ans je dis
tout art confondu qu'est-ce que vous
ressentez quand vous faites de l'art
Orion toujours au taquet
je reçois un se ressent un apaisement ok
Maëlle et Maëlle féminin et mal au
masculin me disent mais oui c'est
exactement ça en fait on ressent comme
une espèce de respiration collective un
apaisement collectif est-ce que
justement on est dans un espace où on a
beaucoup de liberté
et puis bien sûr alors on se met ensuite
Camille qui qui est un peu plus sérieuse
qui dit moi ce que j'aime justement
c'est que ça me sort de la vie
quotidienne et puis c'est intéressant
parce que je peux imaginer tout sorte de
choses en fait je peux ouvrir mes
limites du coup là me permet de penser
Soraya elle plus sage c'est plutôt
thérapeutique pour moi ce que j'ai elle
est assez bonne en dessin effectivement
donc moi j'aime bien dessiner etc
j'éprouve du plaisir quand je le fais
j'éprouve du plaisir après parce que
j'ai une certaine satisfaction et ça
perdure assez longtemps même quand je
revois les dessins ou les dessins des
autres ça me rappelle cette joie que
j'ai éprouvée en pratiquant les arbres
c'est
d'un ennui mortel bon à part que j'aime
bien on a contemporain on peut fabriquer
toutes sortes de choses même des trucs
moches enfin tu essayes d'avoir du style
tu en as pas tu essayes de pas en avoir
tu en as alors c'est compliqué du coup
je ne sais jamais bien sûr toujours
c'est l'urgent si c'est de l'art ou pas
et moi j'ai bien que ce soit beau pour
que ça soit de l'art
reprend et Diallo moi c'est exactement
l'inverse ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
justement pour une fois c'est pas le
beau qui compte c'est pas le résultat
qui compte ce qui compte c'est d'où on
est parti et
par où est-ce qu'on passe pour arriver
là
c'est vrai et à ce moment-là on a elle
qui reprend la parole et qui dit mais
c'est exactement ça
c'est comme quand tu chantes c'est comme
quand tu danses finalement
le rendu puis il pense
quand tu es en train de le faire tu
penses plus et une fois que tu l'as fait
tu es content de l'avoir fait
tu es fier de l'avoir fait l'art ça te
donne du courage ça donne le courage de
vivre
quand même donc du coup je me dis bon
déjà là sont vraiment indispensables je
n'ai aucun doute pas
je le vois et je le vis tous les jours
avec mes élèves
bon après
c'est vrai que c'est très marginal en la
scolarité et que tout le monde ne le
reconnaît pas
forcément et que souvent
petit à petit même chez les élèves ils
ont tendance à perdre le feu sacré
parce qu'ils sont
asphyxiés à se fixés par une globalité
scolaire trop lourde asphyxier
c'est exercer une contrainte trop forte
c'est privé être privé d'un élément
vital or l'art est vital alors nous
privons pas nos enfants de leur
créativité ainsi j'affirme que les arts
plastiques sont la discipline la plus
importante de toute la scolarité et ce
n'est pas seulement je pouvais sur les
mots c'est pas seulement ça c'est aussi
changer de point de vue avoir un autre
vision sur le monde
la plupart du temps on a effectivement
simplement vous vous avez les
réalisations des élèves c'est juste la
toute petite partie de l'iceberg mais
c'est vrai que ce qui intéresse c'est
tout le chemin parcouru parce que de
quoi est-ce qu'on parle exactement
en marre
on a
on parle de plein de choses différentes
on aime connaître le sens des mots on
aime le discuter on ne se contente
jamais d'un bon premier postulat jamais
et oui parce que on a c'est une démarche
intellectuelle qui passe par le
cheminement du corps
et comme on a il y a la variété des
propositions on va avoir
un problème commun
qu'on voit tous ensemble et chacun va
avoir sa réponse c'est pour ça que dans
le jargon professionnel il y a ce qu'on
appelle la mort
la mort consiste à inciter les élèves à
passer immédiatement à la pratique
pourquoi parce qu'on a on réfléchit avec
les mains du coup il faut forcément
essayer d'accord mais la réalisation est
secondaire
si on combat aux mathématiques
quand vos élèves vont en cours de
mathématiques est-ce que vous vous
attendez à ce qu'il soit Pythagore ou
Thalès
quand ils vont en anglais ce que vous
attendez à ce qu'il soit le roi
d'Angleterre
du coup
quand ils vont en art pourquoi
devrait-il avoir le talent de
Michel-Ange ou de Léonard de Vinci
ce n'est pas du tout la question
d'accord et les enfants le savent
d'ailleurs c'est bien pour ça que des
fois peut-être qu'ils font pas assez
d'efforts pour que les choses soient
bien solidaires donc il peut y avoir des
assemblages qui sont pas très solidaires
mais bon peu importe le principal c'est
qu'il y ait un engagement
et dans cet engagement il est insufflé
par la Morse par exemple
faire entrer un géant dans une boîte à
mouchoirs c'est un problème qui semble
absolument soluble au départ bon mais il
y a mille façons de résoudre ce problème
on peut découper un jeu de papier qu'on
découpe en petits morceaux on peut faire
entrer une ombre on peut juste écrire
géant sur un tout petit bout de papier
bon l'écrire lettre majuscule pour quand
même rester conforme à la Morse
voilà on peut faire toutes sortes de
choses et c'est ça qui est intéressant
donc on a une amorce avec planète verte
la planète verte c'est voilà bon
forcément c'est colo on comprend bien
puis du coup sophie me dit mais attends
c'est quand même incroyable
sur ce sujet là le message change
si la planète elle est florifère
végétale luxuriante on sent le message
optimiste des messages écolo
oui
on sent comme une dénonciation
de la pollution
et oui on a il y a un message
et comme le disait Charlotte Perriand
ce qui compte
alors si on ne fait que
reproduire ne progresse plus
pour progresser il faut créer
l'art est existentielle
là c'est ce qu'il y a de plus important
dans nos vies il est partout et en toute
chose d'accord
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui vient se
rajouter ce n'est pas quelque chose de
joli
non c'est pas décoratif
substantiel
alors
depuis l'âge de Cavenne depuis l'âge des
cavernes
l'homme c'est distinguer de toutes les
espèces grâce à sa spiritualité
et à sa créativité
l'art est le propre de l'homme
et c'est pour cette raison
que tout ce que je vous souhaite
c'est plus d'armes dans votre vie
[Applaudissements]
merci